live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
that is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw
as the status symbol of choice we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships george campbell ramsey
personality host of the fine print on
the ramsey networks is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five the call is free and some say the
advice is worth exactly what you pay for
it you jump in we'll talk we're going to
start with matt this hour matt is in
atlanta georgia hi matt how are you
good dave how are you better than i
deserve sir what's up in your world uh
not much um i've got a question for you
in regards to
selling a house
uh me and my wife are in the process of
selling that we have about
250 000 in equity yay and we are playing
yes we are planning to move to my
parents house for
two to five years why
uh they are
in the process of buying a house in
florida and not quite ready to sell
their
main
uh property
so they won't be there while you live
there
they will not
but they're letting you live there for
for free
correct
and then you're going to buy it later
correct
or somewhere else we're not quite sure
how that will work out so it's part of
the deal they're not making you buy this
house eventually
no we're not okay um
is not
forced by
but we want we want that equity of our
house to continue to grow
right now my wife and i
are still working through baby step two
we have about thirty thousand dollars
left to pay off
um
and just trying to decide if we
continue to use
the equity in our house to pay off our
our debts or put that money towards
something that can continue to grow for
us did i hear 35 000 clears it and you
got 250
correct okay that's a no-brainer do that
for sure then we still park the rest of
it for the future house purchase right
correct okay i got to go back to the
deal because i'm struggling
okay i need a little bit of detail here
um so mom and dad are moving out of
their house
and you're going to move into it and
live there free
for three to five years
correct where are mom and dad moving
they are moving to florida
what are they going to live in
a rental are they buying or
they're they're buying a house in
florida have i actually already bought
it why are they not selling you this
house now
um i don't quite know i wouldn't want to
buy this house
we're just doing this my wife and i to
help them
a little bit through the process of
whether or not they want to move to
florida
for the foreseeable future or future or
if they want to move back to georgia
and and live in their house how old are
you uh 30 years old a little old to be
doing house sitting
yeah i agree
this is weird especially for five years
i think they need to paint or get off
the ladder
if they're going to florida they need to
sell their house and you need to go buy
a house
yeah here's the problem here's the
problem with your deal okay it's a nice
thing for them and it sounds good
because you're getting to live there for
free right
right but the problem is that in the
next five years houses will have gone up
in value
and you will have been out of the market
that whole time while you house set for
parents who are indecisive
right
i don't think this is a good deal for
you
okay i want you to be a homeowner
with i mean and you got 250 or 215 000
after we paid off your debt
so if you don't want to buy this house i
would go buy a different house but you
sold your house for the sole purpose of
doing this deal
yes and and my wife and i do love the
property
um if if
we probably would purchase
i'm sorry i should say again
my wife and i it's a family property we
love the property
if if the opportunity arises and we can
buy the house for my parents i would i
would do so all right i was just talking
to a guy a minute ago who said he didn't
want to buy this house
where did he go
it's not for sale right now we're we i'm
not 100 sold on it that we would
purchase this house if it was on the
market
it's quite a bit out of our budget
um
but you know the property is great and
uh what's the property worth
uh probably a hundred uh sorry 1.5
million
yeah it is out of you well i don't know
what do you make a year what's your
household income
uh we make uh 120. yeah it's out of your
budget okay what would they what would
they sell it to you for would it be
value
it would uh they they bought it at an
auction and
it's
they got a great deal out of it
if we were to buy it it would have to be
kind of a non-interest uh
long-term buyout of the home
which i'm not okay here's what here's if
you're going to go forward with this
deal here's the only way you don't get
burnt um i still think the deal is
squirrely because it sounds so like
indecisive
and you're getting in the middle of
other people's being indecisive and
that's always a bad that's like playing
in the traffic
okay so um
the uh but what i do want you to do is i
want them to give you a written
option to purchase
on this property
today
a right to buy
a set price
that you makes you smile
okay and i want you to record that
option at the courthouse as a lien on
the title
do this legally like this was done with
strangers
okay okay and that's how you do business
with family too by the way not because
we think family's going to screw us but
because we half but do stuff because we
think they're not going to screw us and
then they do so then you get all you do
business right
okay but you need to lock in the price
at today's values
and makes you smile and if that's a
million dollar purchase for a million
and a half house
do that
live there three or four years at least
then you're not the all the other
properties around you in life are not
going up in value and you get you lose
all of that appreciation the next five
years while you're a glorified house
sitter
right so lock in can you do that
i
could do that yeah that's otherwise
you're burnt man you're burnt on you're
losing all the appreciation of the next
five years
and then park your money in some mutual
funds with a smartvestor pro after you
pay off your debts and have your
emergency fund in place yeah and even
then if he purchased it for a million he
might have to take out a mortgage for
700 000 which may be way beyond might be
but it might not be but if he's got an
option for five years
or a right to you know first right
they're living there for free for five
years they can save up like crazy people
while their other money goes there we go
there we go yeah now you take 120 000
and you take
what 2 2500 bucks a month that was your
normal house payment or whatever and you
go bonkers and pile up cash that's 30
000 bucks a year plus growth and you do
that that's another that's another
hundred fifty two hundred thousand put
on this now we're starting to get there
yeah so you get a deal locked in and you
use this time to save like crazy
then you get there and you don't even
have to do a mortgage with them i
wouldn't do a mortgage with them long
term i don't recommend that even if it's
zero percent but i would get a deeply
discounted price from them gladly
and lock that in in a formal option
today don't do this deal
if you don't because you're going to get
burnt here man this is going to leave
you out of the market for five years and
that's not a good place to be real
estate is not crashing during this five
years it's going up
this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personalities my
co-host if you haven't heard the news
the sky is not falling the apocalypse is
not here and the housing market is not
going to crash
i know this isn't what you're hearing
from tick-tock where all the best
economists hang out but
oh that was funny
but anyway the truth is you have to look
at facts and most of what's happening is
simple supply and demand there was a
huge spike in home buying demand in the
last couple of years and there weren't
enough houses to keep up and that's why
houses skyrocketed we still have a
housing shortage a tremendous inventory
shortage demand is lower than it was no
question people have slowed down on the
buying and it's more normalized the
market if you want to know more watch
our real estate reality
check
live stream that we did
almost 400 000 people have now viewed
this it was a big hit it's completely
free for you to watch george campbell
rachel cruz and i discussing the details
in the actual data with actual charts
and graphs and stuff it's kind of cool
ramsay solutions dot com slash reality
check and you'll find out what's really
happening in the real world
not what the news says
ramsey solutions dot com slash
reality check
our question today comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings free samples free
shipping and new promos all the time
always use the magic word when you go to
blinds.com it's the promo code ramsey
today's question comes from mike in
texas
he says my wife and i are debt-free
except our mortgage and a 401k loan that
we use to pay off consumer debt we
desperately want to move out
but we apparently miss the best time to
sell our home it's a beautiful house on
a big corner lot since interest rates
went up dramatically our home just sits
on the market we've dropped our asking
price as low as we can do we need to be
patient with the current housing market
or take it off the market and try again
next year
good question from mike
so it's it was an amazing time it's
still a good time
to sell the home so there may be other
factors here dave that we don't know
about about this home sitting on the
market
yeah that's probably true we don't know
how long it's been sitting either he
hasn't said yeah i mean i i have met
people who put their house on the market
and two weeks later are panicking
because it hasn't sold that's the
question has it been two weeks or has
been four months there's a difference or
has it been four years i don't know i
mean
i missed it i missed the one chance
no
you didn't um so here's the thing i
don't know if you have an unrealistic
view of what the house is worth
uh we've taken it as low as we can what
does that mean
okay so here's what i would do
um
number one the housing market we just
talked about that a second ago has
slowed down and sellers are experiencing
a more normal process
for 50 years
with the exception of a two-year period
of time that we recently came through
the normal days on the market for a
house selling was somewhere in the 60 to
120 day range
you know two to four months
that was a normal time to sell a house
i mean and there's been times it was a
little bit slower and times it was a
little bit faster
but in general that's what it was and
then we went through this two-year
period of time where after covid people
came out of their caves looking for
houses like baptist after a casserole
they were going nuts
and they drove these you know house was
on the market for 32 minutes and had 87
offers
and that spoiler by rotten so here's the
deal we're back to a normal market it's
a 90
to 120 day days on the market dom period
that we're sitting in and you have to
have the house completely
merchandised and staged and ready to go
you need to clean the freaking bushes at
the front yard so when you're standing
the street it doesn't look like trash
lives there curb appeal curb appeal
bubba you know and you gotta clean up
the dadgum and you gotta get the cat has
to go visit somewhere else because
nobody buys a house with a dadgum cat in
it and so on right and and so you can't
just put any old piece of trash on the
market and sell instantly anymore so i
don't know if you've got those kinds of
problems the other problem you may have
is an unrealistic view of what the price
is
see values have not come down
prices have
because prices were many times someone
fishing for
uh a sucker
a sucker fish
and they were looking for a sucker and
the price you price it at sucker price
and go if sells for that i'll be a happy
boy you know and but then you come down
you recently bought a property where a
guy was fishing for suckerfish oh yeah
and you made him an offer complete with
all the data that says the appraisal is
worth less than you are asking and you
didn't steal the house but you got it at
appraisal yes when you look at the comps
in the neighborhood and go what have
homes actually closed for in the last 30
or 60 days that gives you a much better
idea of what this home is actually worth
do not go to zillow and go my house is
worth 850 000 according to zillow oh god
so it should sell for 850 because zillow
said so
zillow is not just no you remember the
old map quest thing oh yeah which pretty
much was greek for guaranteed to be lost
zillow is the map quest of real estate
you heard it here first so yeah don't no
no i mean it's okay to look at it
do people still use map quests no i mean
old people are the only ones even know
about it so but um i mean you know yeah
the dial up
yeah and you print off the instructions
out of the paper 14-4 right so um
anyway the the point being get a real
real estate agent and get a real value
and really stage the house put your feet
up
and get ready to ride it out for 90 to
120 days
and if in that period of time you don't
sell it then something else is going on
okay
but i think you might have an
unrealistic view of how fast the market
is i think you might have an unrealistic
view of the value of your home versus
the price you put on it
and the last thing is you're in texas
you could be sitting near some of the
areas that have been hammered
by the
oil by the energy
world being turned upside down and a lot
of people aren't working and some of
those individual markets are actually
declining
uh it's not an it's not a nationwide
thing but you know you've got a mac a
microeconomic situation going on in that
community where a vast percentage vastly
large percentage of the buyers were
in the oil business in one way or
another and now they're not buying
nothing because they got a job or they
don't have an income and so that can
cause a little miniature recession in a
certain area that can affect your house
price
that could be a thing i don't think
that's what's going on here no i think
one of the other things we talked about
is what's going on i'd get an opinion
from one of our trusted real estate
agents and go hey look at this thing
what do you think what do you think is
going wrong here and it may be time to
switch real estate agents if they're not
doing a great job getting some showings
and offers you need to have a realistic
price with realistic length of time
expectations a high prof high quality
professional real estate go to
ramseysolutions.com click on elp for
ramsey trusted people
and
you've got a stage of the house and
actually market it and you know get it
ready to sell to the public which
generally has no imagination and so if
crap is all torn up in there they can't
see past it
and you won't sell the house that's how
houses have been marketed for 50 years
yeah and we talk a lot about this in our
real estate reality check event of what
is actually going on the market what is
it still a good time to buy is it still
a good time to sell and we show the
graph of the interest rates over time
and even though interest rates are going
up they're nowhere near what they were
back when you were selling real estate
no no not i mean even when i started
this show
they were they were in double digits
when we started the show 30 years ago
wow and now if we had double digit
interest rates i mean if we had if we
had a 10 interest rate can you imagine
the whaling and gnashing of teeth
can you imagine but we were in 10
interest rate coming down from 18 so we
were calling that blessed and you were
still selling houses at 18 interest
rates yeah not a bunch but they were
selling yeah yeah absolutely wow you
were just a great real estate agent yeah
that's exactly i'm just that's because
it was at 22 years old i was a genius
yeah all right alan is with us in
cheyenne wyoming hey alan what's up
hi how are you doing guys hey i got a
quick question for you um
our son wants to buy his first house
cool he earns about a hundred thousand
dollars a year um and he has forty
thousand dollars in savings good
the question is i'm trying to figure out
how to financially help him
you know get to twenty percent down or
or get awful close to it um without you
know uncle sam reaching in going well i
want some of your money that you want to
give to your son you can gift him up to
fifteen thousand your wife could gift
him up to another fifteen thousand you
could gift your daughter-in-law another
fifteen thousand and she could gift your
daughter-in-law another fifteen thousand
so up to sixty thousand you can avoid
gift tax simply by writing up to four
checks and making them from one
individual to another not exceeding
fifteen thousand
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over
companies use netsuite by oracle
including ramsey solutions because
netsuite gives us a single view of
everything we need to make daily
decisions whether you're making a few
million to hundreds of millions a year
netsuite gives you the visibility and
control of the things you need to grow
like your financials inventory hr
planning budgeting and more all in one
dashboard go to netsuite.com ramsey
right now to get their free white paper
jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personalities my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america nathan is with us in gainesville
florida hi nathan welcome to the ramsey
show
hey thank you all for having me on sure
what's up
um my question today is i have
i'm closing on a house august 5th
and i currently have a car i owe 8 800
on i could resell it for 15.
but i've had kind of a hard time finding
anything that's even slightly reliable
around that six to seven thousand mark
so i'm wondering if i should just um
punch out paying it off or search for
something that will
you know work for around that price
i would continue to do the research and
and get a 7 000 car
before you get into this house
what's your other plan if you don't do
that
my other plan is that to keep the car
pay it off and i have quite a bit of
repairs i need to be doing on the house
i'm currently living
rent free with my grandpa so i don't
have to worry about
payments until i get the house which um
is
you know next month
um but i've budgeted all that out i've
used every dollar and
uh i think i'll be i'll be fine with the
payments but what do you make a year
um around 40. no whining sell your car
and find a six thousand dollar car
and don't tell me there's no such thing
as a six thousand dollar car that's
reliable that's absolute bs
yeah
okay dude you're about to get yourself
in a pinch rationalizing your butt off
here
okay yeah yeah you're trying to do 17
things at once you know what you're
supposed to do you just wanted one of us
to tell you
what kind of car is this that you have
um it's a passat volkswagen
yeah you need to sell that anyway just
get a honda or toyota
and you'll be fine yeah yeah just get
you an old honda toyota village they'll
go 300 000 miles easy dadgum honda
accords man they they really never just
die they never really died they just
kind of stood them if you wanted to just
go forever
yeah you got to just do some shopping
around and and here's the thing you just
don't want to sell the car
you just don't want to make the move you
don't want to downgrading car now you
shouldn't have boxed yourself in if you
want to keep this car but now you got
this house that needs all these repairs
you make 40 grand a year you're living
with your grandpa do you do these
repairs you got this house payment
coming on on a house that still needs
repairs and now you're talking about
keeping a car payment no
i feel stressed just hearing all that
made me stressed
yeah i want to get into this house and
have it be a blessing and not a curse
and that means no debt no payments other
than we're focusing on this house we
tell folks all the time nathan you
included don't buy a home while you have
debt
what
yeah really because murphy will move in
your spare bedroom sally may move in the
other bedroom heat and air will go out
the first week you move in the roof will
leak the third week you move in you're
asking for trouble when you move into a
house with a bunch of debt
and people rationalize it all the time
and they keep getting more and more debt
more and more debt more and more debt
and they get stressed out and then they
get the they get the crap knocked out of
them by life then and so but i i do the
same thing i try to figure out a way to
get to do all the stuff i want to do at
the same time where none of us like
saying no even to ourselves but
i guess it's kind of one of our
spiritual gifts here at the show we're
supposed to be here just to tell you
what you already knew
uh no you don't need to keep this car
uh if you were going to keep this car
you shouldn't have bought this house and
too late you've already bought this
house so yeah you need something's got
to go and if you can get out from under
this car and make profit i'm doing that
oh definitely hannah is in ann arbor hi
hannah how are you
hello
what's up
hi i have a question in regards to kind
of housing market and housing grants
first off we make roughly
seven thousand or seventy thousand
dollars
um my husband's in part 10 ministry he
does also a w-2 i'm a 1099.
um and that's combined together that we
make um do you guys
are just trying to get out of a
kind of a
profits chamber kind of situation
situation
uh we live on our church property
oh okay all right
yeah okay um and so it's it's good but
it's it has its setbacks too we've been
there for three years it's been great
but we just need to get out now we kind
of have a time frame that we need to get
outside
um and we're just wondering
we follow your baby steps we're out of
credit card debt we only have our car
loan and we're trying to stock you know
pay that off as fast as we can but also
put away money at the same time because
we have a time frame to get out and so
our perspective our question is what do
you guys think about housing grants i do
live in michigan if that kind of what
kind of housing grant are you looking at
um it's what's called a misha grant
it they changed a few years ago it used
to be forgivable it's not forgivable now
is my understanding you do have to pay
that back when you sell it
um or you refinance the house
it's up to what we qualify for what i'm
told is 10 grand
so they give you 10 grand that you have
to give them back the first time you
refinance or sell
correct that is my under that is my
understanding i think there's probably
some other strings to this that you need
to understand that are probably going to
make this less than palatable
okay when you get further into it i
doubt it is quite as simple as i don't
know i don't know the program but i
doubt i mean i've been in the real
estate in and around real estate my
whole life and so
lots of first-time homebuyer programs
out there across the nation this sounds
like it might have some other things
tied to it i would learn about that but
i also wouldn't tell you to buy a house
right now you're broke
you just need to go rent something
okay you don't need to be buying a house
with a car payment
yes how much do you owe on your car
uh eight yeah actually seven and why is
your husband part-time does he have a
full-time job in addition to that
yes he does he works four days a week
for a w-2
um what does he do four days a week
he works at a
he
chemical company i guess at the shipping
he's a shipping manager okay good okay
and so but his heart is in ministry and
so he took a yes an additional part-time
job as a
as a pastor and they with that gave you
guys a personal juice and now that's
coming to an end
yeah pretty much yeah
yeah i'd be getting out of debt and
let's go rent somewhere let's get an
emergency fund in place of three to six
months then we can focus on our down
payment this is all while we're renting
how much have you got the savings
um
roughly 13. 15 000.
yes 13 000. 13 000.
your only debt is an 8 000 car
yes great pay it off when you get off
the phone please
okay today
i want you to be free and then i want
you to save aggressively can you stay in
the parsonage a little while longer and
with no car payment quickly build up a
down payment if not
then i'm going to have you go rent for
six months and build up your down
payment that way
okay please don't move into a house with
a car please please for your sake don't
move into a house with a car payment
you're asking okay for trouble
you're you're letting the timing of this
parsonage deal running out
drive your financial decisions instead
of wise financial decision making
you're being forced into doing something
you feel like you're being forced into
doing something dumb and and rent in
your case is just buying some time it's
patience
so if you have to rent for six months or
a year while you build up your down
payment fine but pay off your car today
today
and these grants they often seem like
wow they're really helping us out but i
just heard this is a loan
yeah it's like these student loans these
they go oh we're going to give you
scholarships and grants no you gave me a
subsidized loan thank you so much
doesn't have any interest on i mean i
did we did i was doing rehabs years ago
i took a historic grant on a historic
house they gave me five thousand dollars
for to do repairs
but what came with it was everything on
the house had to be put back by the way
they defined historic period which
included no railing around the front
porch which codes required that's
complicated so i either have to do what
the hysteric people want me to do or i
have to do what codes wants me to do but
if i don't do what the historic people
say i don't get the five thousand
dollars and if i do the hysteric thing
then then codes won't give me a use and
occupancy permit so i'm like why don't
you people that all work for the
government get together and like talk
and stuff that sounds too difficult you
know but
there's a reason that codes came up with
um
railings around front porches since 1901
because people kept falling off and
breaking their faces but dave history
there it is preserve the history yeah
but we want the history of the broken
face oh my god but this is grants
there's always something tied in there
and i'm always a little attached i'm
from you know the scariest words in the
english language i'm from the government
i'm here to help this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the ramsey show george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today scott's in indianapolis
hey scott how are you
real good thank you i appreciate you
taking my call sure what's up
hey uh recently i'm tired i'm 62.
uh not taking social security yet uh i
rolled my 41k over into an ira uh
about about 208 000 in a pension
i didn't know if i should pay my car my
live student loan or her call was my
student
loan and the house off how much does all
that add up to
about 80 000
which would leave you with a hundred
twenty eight thousand dollars right
roughly that i have to pay tax on it
because it wasn't taxed yeah you have
any other nest egg
13
you don't have another 401 k your wife
doesn't have anything else this is it
well she's got a 401k they started about
two years ago
she may have around 16 in it right now
okay
but the 401k that i had i've rolled that
over into an ira how much you owe in
your car
uh about nine
95 roughly and what's the student loan
about 95 about 59
five along the house
okay so 60 000 on the house 20 000 on
the other stuff
right okay
i would pay off the other stuff for sure
and uh you're 62 how old is she
uh she's 62 also did you say you retired
uh from the job i was at yes are you
working
i'm not working right now i can go back
to work if i want but i don't want to i
don't blame you and uh does she work
yes so what is your household income
with you being retired
uh
with just her i'm gonna guess about 45
to 50.
okay
when did she take out these student
loans
um
i'm gonna guess two or three years ago
maybe longer oh so she just recently
went to school
well see when she did go to it she
dropped out of it it was all computer
classes over yeah
on the computer she didn't actually go
to a school okay here's what's bouncing
around in my mind scott and you guys can
talk about this tonight and decide what
you want to do okay
i don't like leaving you only a hundred
thousand bucks
right that's a small nest egg
that can go away in about three blinks
right that scares me
okay uh i don't like any of this but i
really don't like that i don't like that
feeling you see what i'm saying
right so what i would probably do if i
woke up in your shoes i don't like
because i don't like the strain of being
that broke at 62.
um i would write a check today and pay
off
the the two little debts
and then i would take some kind of fun
thing that makes me smile that's not
that pays really really ridiculously
good what did you used to do
uh worked
in the propane business
what did you do in the propane business
okay regulators and i was a mechanic
you okay
so is there some kind of tinkering
turning of a wrench that makes you smile
that you enjoy doing
yeah like burger in my hands yeah i mean
you sound like you're that guy or
volcanic
kind of a handyman i guess yeah i mean
if you could if you could if you could
tinker around and make
60 000 over the next couple years and
pay the house off
that'd be pretty
cool okay without without breaking your
back and screwing up your retirement
happiness right
yeah but i mean you don't have to take
80 hours a week unless you want to work
80 hours a week for six months and get
this over with i don't know but um i
doubt that's available it could be i
don't know
but i mean if there's some and a lot of
stuff like this might be you just
starting some kind of little side thing
like handyman people are paying
ridiculous money for handyman i'm one of
those people dave are you gonna make 50
75 bucks an hour just doing general
handyman work stuff george george
doesn't know what a screwdriver is
exactly i'm not talking back breaking
stuff but it's stuff that you know how
to do and other people don't yeah you
get get get a good millennial like
george that doesn't know what a
screwdriver is and charge him a lot i'd
rather watch netflix than hang pictures
up dave i'm sorry that's my generation
i'm sorry it's just pitiful choices but
i like i like the idea of paying off the
little debts knocking them out and then
getting back to work for a short period
of time getting rid of all the payments
here's the thing scott you might mess
around with this handyman thing and make
a lot of money doing it and it might
actually be fun
if you didn't because you don't have to
do it it's no longer work it's like the
cool thing i'm doing oh and by the way
i'm gonna pay the house off when the
house is paid off and you've got 150 000
bucks in there a little more than that
your wife's 401ks continue to build for
a couple three more years y'all's nest
egg starts to be you know bumping up
maybe two 300 now i'm feeling a lot more
comfortable yeah you can actually retire
forward dignity feeling more comfortable
for you
christians with us in san jose hi
christian welcome to the ramsey show
hello mr ramsay hello mr camel how you
guys doing great man what's up
hey so my question is whether or not i
should sell my home uh with my wife and
either rent something out or
buy a new home
okay why would you do that
um so right now we live in hollister
california um our commute is about an
hour
um when we do commute uh usually we just
stay with my mother-in-law
so we're rarely ever at home
okay well it does sound like a move is
in order in the direction of your work
what do you make of your household
income
uh together we make approximately 180 to
200 000 a year cool that's good news
well you live in a super expensive area
so i was hoping you made some money
um
yeah so if you sell and re-buy in the
other area that's closer does that work
the thing is right now our current home
we owe 545 000 it's
approximately 100 or 830 000
which is what it's worth
but everything we're looking for in san
jose california is approximately 1.2
million yeah i bet
uh great news is you make 180 right
yes sir yeah so what i would do uh is
quit looking at 1.2 i mean that that may
be the worst house in san jose it's
possible that's a super high area
but the uh but i'm going to really try
to find the house that's even worse than
that
that you're just really ashamed of and
hate in and at least make your move and
get your life back on the commute
and then start saving like crazy and
move up into a little better house in
that same community then
but i'm not you know all of this
together does not equal buy something
you can't afford and beats the crap out
of you with the monthly payment and
you're sitting in the corner sucking
your thumb because your house poor
nothing is worth that i understand yeah
don't do that so can you split the
difference and maybe you live 20 minutes
out from san jose and you can find a
place that's
you know eight hundred thousand seven
hundred now twenty minutes out is what
he's talking about i mean it's it's it's
that's just
you're just dealing with silicon valley
man i mean it's just unbelievable yeah
it's gross
i mean it it it's it's a ridiculous
world when you make 180 000 and can't
live and that's a lot that's a crazy
word but it is the world you're in dude
i mean it's
uh i mean
you got kids yeah i mean it's just i i
think you i think you start trying to
make the move but you just make it super
conservative
and
uncomfortable you're gonna choose your
discomfort yeah choose the our commute
or a house that sucks
as a stepping stone to a house that
doesn't suck and that you build up with
you because your income you're young
enough your incomes are going to
continue to go up
you're in that market and man that's
tough because even with you know 280
down on the new one yeah on a 1.2 you're
looking at an astronomical monthly
payment oh yeah yeah even making sure
it's just it's just hard
but that's you don't get passed on math
you can't
you got to have the income to do the
deal
regardless you don't get a pass just
because i chose to live there it means
you can't live there or whatever so it's
um when i was growing up we lived
across the tracks on the other side of
the tracks over here literally i mean
behind me there's some tracks and so
one county over from here and this
county that we're in is a very wealthy
county
and uh we used to talk about the rich
people that lived over here and we went
you can't live over there you know we we
could before we weren't big
poor people were here yeah it's
expensive
and so that's just what you're facing i
mean sometimes you look across the
tracks and you just can't afford to live
over there
uh and until your income changes or
something else gotta adjust your
expectations it's hard to do that's hard
that puts us hour the ramsey show in the
books george camel
james andrew zach ben and austin in the
booth this is the ramsey show
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they really love and create actual
amazing relationships george campbell
ramsey personality host of the fine
print on ramsey networks is my co-host
today open phones here at triple eight
eight two five 825-5225
nancy's in orlando to start off this
hour hi nancy how are you
hey there dave and george fine thank you
and thank you for my call sure what's up
um my husband and i are in baby step
seven and we want to set the goal of
being baby step millionaires but i don't
know how to establish our current net
worth we primarily off of his post
office pension but since it's not a
liquid lump sum i'm guessing we can't
include it so i can't determine a per
month investment goal because the riq
process doesn't include the pension or
are paid for home so i don't know where
to start ah very cool well you're right
technically speaking a pension is not
part of your net worth because you can't
sell it or you can't cash it out and use
it
and so it's just a stream of income
that's promised to you in other words
social security is not part of my net
worth but i'll be getting social
security someday right
so it's the same thing
but because net worth is assets minus
liabilities
but that's not really your issue i mean
it'd be it's fun for you to keep up with
your net worth and
um you know you've got a when you have a
a baby steps from when your baby steps
millionaire you have a million dollar
net worth and on top of that have this
pension life's gonna be pretty sweet you
know so
what you're looking at is just your 401k
and your house and you know what you own
minus what you owe is the thing and then
as far as calculating it go what your
need is
you know you just basically say
i'm you know figure out what it is i'm
going to need per month and working in
your riq
and then
take the pension out of that because you
got the pension so if your need is five
thousand dollars a month and you got
three thousand dollars worth of pension
then your net need is two thousand
dollars
that make sense
yes with us with us in our 60s i don't
know that we'll live long enough to
actually hit millionaire status be an
optimist nancy
what's your house worth
uh probably 300. okay and what's in your
401k
[Music]
pro 32
okay okay all right so you've got a 300
000 350 000 net worth probably right you
have other assets that we're not
discussing here
no okay and are you both working still
yes and what's your household income
oh
good question i would say 55
okay
um just depends on how long you live
you'll probably get there in your 70s
somewhere
if you continue if you continue to save
pretty aggressively because the house is
going to go up in value and you're going
to continue to add to a 401k that's
assuming you're working and adding money
to it now if you quit work it's 62 you
know no you're probably not going to get
there
but it's okay if you don't it's okay if
you don't the million-dollar net worth
is not a magic thing it's just a measure
of net worth that's all it is and so the
question of is it enough
well if you have what's your pension
going to pay you
oh we can already live off the pension
what's the pension going to pay the
issue
um we're getting 24
and then he's already taking ssi and i'm
keep on holding off until age 70. i'm
sorry
you broke up when you gave me the number
how much are you getting well i'm sorry
um his pension's 2460
and then he's currently getting his
social security i won't take mine until
i'm 70. 2 460 a month
yes okay all right so you got a nice
pension plus your social or your ssi and
stuff and so yeah you guys can make it
on that so you're not in trouble
um it's just it's just kind of a math
game it's a monopoly game now you're
just it's a fun milestone along the
journey but can you have a great
retirement and not get there sure can
you have a terrible one depending on
your lifestyle and what's going on
absolutely if you want to spend 60 000 a
year you're gonna have a terrible one
yes so we'll have to adjust
to do that
uh but if you keep your income your
lifestyle below your pension income
uh and continue to save and grow the
other stuff then yeah you could end up
with a lot of situation there which goes
along with our original principle live
on less than you make that applies in
baby step one and seven there you go
it's a key principle and we have we do
have a great net worth calculator at
ramseysolutions.com that if you're
listening and you're curious you can
jump on there and it'll add up all the
assets it'll add up all the liabilities
and do the math for you
joe is in fresno except i pushed the
wrong button there joe is in fresno how
are you joe
i am doing great thank you for taking my
call sure how can we help well um
my wife is here to keep the story
straight but
simply
because joe's known for exaggerating
joe's attorney is present
um
we we're we just retired we were both in
education and our
income together is about 6 000 a month
and we live in a house that is worth
roughly around 500 000 and we owe about
268
and so we're in the valley of decision
on do we spend the money to fix it up
kind of what i want and then my wife is
saying
the heck with it uh let's sell it and go
buy another house so she's saying is it
going to be better for us to fix it up
and live in it or do we
cut loose on it and go find maybe a
smaller house where empty nesters like i
said were retired
and just trying to figure things out
figure things out
okay
um
well the answer to the question if it
was my house is uh
what's going to be the how old are you
today
i am 61. okay what's going to be the
best story
when you're 71
which one of these plans gets you
the best life
when you're 71 the fixed up house and
you stayed in it
or the downsize into a newer house and
you didn't have to screw with the
repairs
that's a good question
that's the answer to the question is
which one gives you the best life
because oftentimes what happens is these
things get so close to our face
that we're making a decision based on
the emotions of the next 12 months
rather than the next 12 years
and the 12-year window will give you a
better decision-making paradigm
right what kind of repairs are we
talking joe have you done the math and
what's this kind of cost
yeah i'm thinking it's going to cost
about maybe uh 30 000 which you know
being in education i've decided that i
can go back and do
become a sub teacher and
if i work work
i could probably
make those that much money in a year
and you know get all those little
things that she wants done
um and it still won't be the right house
and be perfect when when it's done why
is it that she wants to move if she
didn't like it when it's done
um that's a good question i think some
of it is that
uh she wants to move into a little
smaller house because
um she's uh you know we're empty nesters
and wanted a little small house maybe
easier to clean who knows i think you
have your answer joe you just answered
it happy wife happy life this ain't the
house this is the ramsey show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and churchill is here to help go to
their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today what's your one day goal
maybe one day i'll be able to buy a
house maybe one day
i'll be happy with my career
one day i won't have to battle with
anxiety anymore one day i'll be out of
that stop waiting around
whatever your one day is you need to
start towards it right now
and that's why we created smart
conference
smart conference is a full day event
where you will hear from best-selling
authors
in on anxiety
on
careers
on money
on leadership
on marriage
the top people
in the nation
all day long in every area of your life
it's only 39 and you can get a four pack
for only 120
and bring some friends
you can't get a concert to i just saw a
thing where adele was 40 000 bucks to
get in
so the tickets are going so i mean you
could buy out the whole smart conference
for that just about your ticket master
fees are more than 40 bucks yeah so 120
bucks and you don't have ticketmaster
with us
we are we are our own ticketmaster we
are our own master
that's right we master our own tickets
thank you very much none of those janky
ramsey solutions dot com slash events
the smart conference is in dallas
saturday october 22nd we're glad you're
coming
uh several thousand of you are already
are already registered and it only holds
like i think it was seven thousand
people's also that's right it will be a
sell out early and you will need to get
your tickets now if you want to go
well george one of the things that
happens in a world gone crazy
is that
people decide they're going to just
change the definitions of things
that's called relativism
and you can just decide
a new definition of a thing by people do
you mean the white house
today it was the white house they
decided they wanted to
to redefine
because they're the white house and they
can do that they get to decide that what
we all thought something was what we've
been taught in every class that we've
ever gone to that something was that it
is not that thing to be fair john
deloney wrote a book called redefining
anxiety see he definitely there it is he
redefined it he redefined decided but
when he finished it was still anxiety
i'll tell you that okay so
so here's a real article from
whitehouse.gov
from the white house website
how do economists determine whether the
economy is in a recession there's the
headline and what does it go on to say
dave this is very interesting
what is a recession
while some maintain that two consecutive
quarters of falling real gdp constitute
a recession
that is neither the official definition
nor the way economists evaluate the
state of the business cycle
uh let me just stop you right there
paul
every econ 101 class
in the united states that was not taught
by the biden administration has defined
a recession since god was a boy as two
consecutive shrinking quarters of the
gdp
ball
okay now let me just make sure i got
that it goes on to say instead both
official determinations of recessions
and economist assessment of economic
activity are based on a holistic look at
the data including labor market consumer
and business spending industrial
production and incomes based on these
data it is unlikely that the decline in
gdp in the first quarter of this year
even if followed by another decline in
the second quarter indicates a recession
if the economy continues to shrink it
must not be a recession because we
decided it wasn't a recession i am
dumber for having read this paragraph
brain cells died while i read this
paragraph how did someone write this in
good conscience and good faith well they
write word solids up there all the time
oh that's right oh my gosh
this is a political word salad yeah
explain why they're doing this because
there's a very clear reason to me well
it's yeah it's classic politics i mean
remember when bill clinton said we had
to define the word is that's right it's
you know it depends on what you're
definitely what you mean by it is is
depends on what you mean by recession
well i actually mean a recession two
consecutive quarters of the gdp
shrinking and that's not a republican or
democrat thing that's just a thing it's
called economics that's just
merriam-webster's opinion dave overdrawn
on your checking account well unless i
decide i don't really want to call it
that i kind of feel like i'm
getting good use of the bank's money was
the money really there holistic approach
to your checking account involves
overdraft fees and
a holistic approach to your uh student
loan is that you keep it your whole
stupid life uh there's a whole i mean
holistic
what are you uh witch doctor
holistic economics this is a whole new
way of getting at this there's going to
be a college course about this very
topic oh my gosh so the real reason is
okay so the real reason the real reason
is politics okay we're going in the
midterm elections and the last thing
that the democrat democratic white house
wants is for the republicans to run
around saying we're in recession because
we actually freaking are and so they
throw a bunch of democrats out or the
voters throw a bunch of democrats out of
office that's all it is they just don't
want to be in a recession going into
these midterms
so this is how they have to change the
definition of recession this is a
thousand percent a pr move uh
political bs yeah that's what it is
okay so yeah depends on what your
definition of red is
blue green
i wonder what the definition is
is this a blue shirt oh i know
holistically looking at the shirt it has
some little black lines in it and i
decided it's going to identify as a
black shirt today instead of a blue
shirt so there you go and we're not
going to identify this as a recession
i'm going to self-identify it as
prosperity maybe the white house is
economically colorblind
there we go
that's one that's one reason there's so
many things i can i'm sorry
i'm not gonna say interesting articles
if you want to get dumber go read it for
yourself at white house god i feel like
i really have
this is like oh this is like the 70s
were the 70s were good to the person
whose parents wrote this oh yeah yeah oh
my god they're like their parents were
had drug use choices were mad at me
while they were doing drugs and that
person wrote this paragraph
oh my god wow lsd was involved i'm just
saying oh my gosh this makes no sense
i don't care i mean listen if trump was
going into a recession
we're going in a recession
if i don't care who puts you there i'm
not even sure we're in one i thought we
were going into one i at least can tell
you that based on the data that will
come out this week you should get the
data this week that the second quarter
may not have shrunk
so this may all be for nothing so what
actually i just offended that we get to
redefine these terms to the convenience
of a politician and if we are or are not
in a recession depends on how do you
define
oh you're right i'm sorry you can't
define r until you've defined is i'm
gonna walk around with a dictionary from
now on
it's the only way well it's relativism
because you have to do critical thinking
that isn't really thinking there's no
source of truth it's just critical
oh boy you people this is exhausting
yeah so here's the thing
let's just pretend that uh when the data
comes out this week that we had two
consecutive quarters of the economy
shrinking here's what we do pretty much
know
that it just barely shrunk and if it
didn't shrink it just barely grew
it basically is right around even
which means it's not prosperous but
we're not all going to hell in a
handbasket so it's not going to be a
hurricane tomorrow we're not prospering
it's not a good economy but it's not a
horrible hurricane we're all going to
die recession either we know that even
if it is a recession it's just not that
much of one it's kind of a light rain
not even a good thunderstorm
and so that people are running around
with their helmets on because the
tornado is coming but the um
but yeah no hey here's
so to biden to biden or the democrats
defense
the republicans are going to make a
whole lot more
uh
deal out of the recession than it really
is the headlines on their side will make
it feel good
it's joe biden's fault that's what
they're going to do right that's not
true either okay because it's just not
that bad it's not that it's not that
stinky of a recession but it's nothing
to walk around bragging about and it's
nothing to be so concerned about that
you have to redefine terms because we
now know that the democratic party does
not know the definition of is
or the definition of a recession because
they change it at will i just want a
fake book cover of john delony and it
says redefining recessions
just as a spoof just yeah someone's
gonna do it now bring that back for
april so the deal is
you don't get to re-define a word
to fit your agenda boys and girls well
you can and some of you have pulled it
off um some of you have taken words and
they mean completely other things now
because of your activism and your areas
that you're in but here's one that
[Music]
well
not gonna work this time one plus one is
two can't change that sorry just two
consecutive quarters of gdp shrink is a
recession
sorry joe
not getting by with that word sally this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage joe and jordan are with
us hey guys how are you good how you
doing dave welcome welcome better than i
deserve where do you live uh quincy
michigan so we're about 40 minutes
southeast of battle creek perfect hey
good to have you guys welcome to
nashville how much debt have you paid
off
265 000 good for you and how long did
that take uh five years uh four and a
half or four months and uh 13 days
that'll work
and your range of income during that
five years four and a half months um the
bulk of it was 118 000 to 171 000 and
then the last six months
joe had gotten a promotion and i took a
job at a new company and that pushed our
income to 240. whoa look at you way to
go guys
okay but five years and 265 000 is that
your house yeah where'd it go where
people thank you how old are you weirdos
i'll be 38 on thursday and i'm 36. you
haven't paid for a house yes you're
weird
i love it
very cool what's the house worth
like 220. yeah awesome phenomenal
phenomenal how much you got in
retirement accounts about 180 yeah so
you're bumping a half million right now
in net worth on your way to be a
millionaire is probably by the time
you're 45 or 50. way to go guys you're
killing it thank you thank you and with
this income probably 45. was there other
debt in here too yes what kind uh so
cell phones was about 2 000 credit cards
2 000
um cars 20 000
150 000 in student loan debts oh there
it is yeah
and then 91 for the house okay wow you
guys are impressive you plowed through a
bunch of stuff here all right tell us
the story what happened five years ago
that got you guys on this journey and
how did you hook up with this ramsey
stuff
so i've heard of you when i was in
college one of my best friends um
mentioned that her brother followed your
program and then i started seeing you on
the news with your little segments and
then i would be driving and see your
billboards and i'm like okay well he's
probably got something there but then it
was december 2016 joe and i were getting
our um tax refund stuff around all the
things we could write off and with the
time it was 2 500 in student loan
interest that you could write off and so
we
you know compiled all our student loans
and we realized we paid over 10 grand
that year just in student loan interest
and um in that same moment joe said just
so you know at the time we just had one
child but
he's like just so you know i want us to
pay for our kids college and
i was like you're nuts like we're gonna
still be paying on our student loans
until we're 50 and he's like well
whatever we're doing that for them i
said well then we need to get our act
together so i ordered your book right
then
i read it in two or three days i relayed
the information to joe and we were game
on total money makeover yep here we go
just all the stuff coming at you and
then all of a sudden you went oh i need
that total money makeover book now yep
sounds like you annoyed yourself into
this plane you're like this dave guy and
all the student loan interest you're
like fine i'll do it well i feel like
maybe i was just too immature to
actually listen
you know so
but once we you know grew up right in
that moment and decided to
you know follow your plan your plan
works if you follow it so yeah
so joe when she comes to you she start
reading this book and she's trying to uh
kind of give you the cliff notes version
and go this is what it says
uh were you resistant
i was dave-ish
um you know and stopping their
retirement and yeah you know saying no
to everything and budget and i was like
yeah you know we can we can dabble we
can see what happens and then
as we started to
get the loans in order and the debt
snowball then i was
gung-ho yeah you kind of saw it you
started you saw it start to click yeah
and i was all in you would pull out our
spreadsheet almost every day and be like
okay like if we could just knock this
one out and you know a month earlier
this you know he was always looking for
ways to speed up the game a little bit
so we're both competitive so having that
goal yeah and beating it that was you
know that was fun for us well the
traction the traction is a big thing
yeah if you don't have that vision of
that goal you're going why are we doing
this you got to have that piece of of
the pie to the piece of the puzzle to go
now i'm angry and like you said where
else can we do we got 200 margin what if
we had 500 how could that speed it up
exactly and it becomes a little bit
addictive yep
in a good way yes absolutely what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is
um i think changing your mindset first
debt is so normal in our society i mean
i was going to order a shirt online and
i noticed you could sign up for
five interest-free payments of four
dollars
thank you klarna yes exactly so
like something's caught in your throat
yes so just changing your mindset that
debt is just a part of life it it is for
so many people but it sucks and it it
takes away from a lot in your future so
changing that mindset and then also
believing that you're deserving of a
great life
and
just following your plan i mean truly if
people just follow your steps they work
if they work them so
yeah there's a lot of shame and guilt
and arrogance that we carry around when
it comes to money when you can just be
an adult look in the mirror and go it
ain't pretty but we're going to fix this
i'm in control yeah that changes
everything i'm so proud of you guys way
to go you guys how does it feel to be
completely free no house payment amazing
it's surreal y'all are wack
what do your friends think about all
this
um they're happy for us they've
encouraged us you know said they're
proud of us and
um they probably think we're weird which
is fine you are normal normal's broke
yeah yeah you guys aren't broke i mean
you got serious net worth not a debt in
the world what's the first big thing
that uh
you guys want to do now that you don't
have a single payment
we're taking the girls up north to the
u.p in michigan for a whole week and
you know experiencing god's country up
there so it is pretty it is yeah yeah
our own uh
uh uh courtney's husband is from up
there and courtney was actually an uh
anchor up there a news anchor up there
for a while up in traverse city and then
oh yeah very much
up there too so yeah it's a beautiful
area very yeah that'll be a fun fun
thing the upper peninsula you people
michigan people yeah
it's like okay hey guys way to go thank
you very fun thank you for everything we
we love seeing people like you you're
you're an inspiration you're amazing
heroes so we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you uh that's the next
chapter in your story for sure how
ordinary people built extraordinary
wealth how you can do it's our latest
number one we got a one year
subscription to financial peace
university if you haven't been go
through it it's the brand new videos
with george and dr john deloney and me
and rachel and uh we'd love to have you
do that or give it to somebody that
needs to get on this plan one of the two
um or buy it for somebody and you go
through i don't care whatever you do and
we've got a copy of total money makeover
giveaway too the thing the book that got
you started so thank you very very well
done all right you brought the kiddos
what are their names and ages okay so
the oldest is logan she is six all right
this is leighton she is four and lane
here is two all right the beautifuls are
in the picture
oh that's so fun
that is so fun look at that that's great
that right there's a good why absolutely
you guys have changed their lives you've
changed their family tree they don't
even know what you've done for them no
but we'll remind them don't worry i'm
reminding them right now they can watch
this video over and over that's right
price that their mom and dad paid live
like no one else so later you can live
and give like no one else so their
college fund got that's what got this
whole thing to start the discussion over
that so that's beautiful well done you
guys you're amazing very well done so
proud of you all right it's joe and
jordan logan leighton and lane from
battle creek michigan area 265
thousand dollars paid off five years
four months 13 days 118 to 171 to 240
income count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
i'm loving this trend dave i'm seeing
we're seeing a lot of people in their
20s 30s paying off their homes early
they're getting right on their verge of
being babysitting millionaires already i
mean they're setting themselves up but
here's the thing
that little girl
is old enough to remember the oldest one
maybe the little maybe the little
four-year-old but certainly the oldest
one logan
the weird day that her weird mom and dad
came to this weird place in tennessee
and screamed they're debt-free and
she'll be a grandma someday telling her
kids
that i have 10 million dollars each
where it all started that's a legacy
worth leaving that's called changing
your family tree
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for joining us america george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today katie's with us in dallas
texas hi katie how are you
[Music]
katie
are you there katie
hi katie yes i'm good how are you great
how can we help
so i'm 27 000
in credit card debt
i've used 100 percent of my credit
does myself a whole and i don't know
how to get out how old are you
i am 32. how much do you make a year
i gross 83.
is this the only debt you've got
it is
this is awesome i'm so glad you're here
this is a good problem to have with this
income katie we can clean this up fast
is it on one card or multiple
it's on six different cards okay that's
one biggest one being discover 12 000.
all right and you clearly want to get
out of this how did you get into it
what'd you spend the the credit card
money on
um just transitioning over from one job
to another
paying my way
got into that
you did not spend 27 000 transitioning
from one job to another
uh
i started out that way and then it kept
growing yeah so it was kind of an
addiction yeah a problem
kept spending
transitioning from one job to another
and you're disorganized and you
overspent buying crap you can't afford
for the rest of it exactly okay okay
so i want to make sure that we at least
change the behavior because we can help
you get out of debt i just don't want
you back in this mess you know two years
from now and so what i want you to do is
cut up the cards we're done with those
you're going to list out the debts from
smallest to largest so the smallest
credit card debt to the largest one
we're not looking at the interest rate
we're not going to do math right now
we're going to work on progress and
getting rid of this debt and so how much
how much could you throw extra at the
credit card debt if you're making
minimum payments on the rest
um
so that's the issue i have after i'm
done paying all of my bills
uh each paycheck i had ten dollars left
the day i got paid you make eighty three
thousand dollars where is it going
all bills
no no you told us that was your only dad
you stop you told us this was your only
day
bill's like for house you know my rent
how much is your rent
uh 800 a month that's not it and then
electric and stuff is 450. mm-hmm my son
goes to a private school
550
a month
are you married um
i'm not a single mom okay
all right so here um
the the first thing is this
the
grasping the idea that personal finance
is 80
behavior
it's only 20 head knowledge
and so behaviors are what got you into
this
new and healthy behaviors are what will
get you out of this is that logical to
you
yes okay absolutely and so what you're
going to do we're going to put you into
financial peace university and help you
that is a nine week class
nine lessons
and we're going to teach you every
detail about handling money
and i'm gonna give it to you for free
it's usually about a hundred dollars to
go through it okay i'm gonna give it to
you free because i've been where you are
scared and didn't know what to do
and you're scared and you're by yourself
trying to raise a kid and you don't know
what to do and that right
yes okay
so what i want you to do is i want you
to use that fear
not as a paralyzing
agent to paralyze you but i wanted to
use you as the driving agent that says i
will never
be here again
i will pay any price i will sacrifice
anything i will do whatever it takes so
that me and my kid are never
on the doorstep of financial terror like
this again
no matter what it takes i'm getting out
no matter what it takes no matter what
dave says i gotta do my friends think
it's weird and it's uncomfortable to me
i'm doing it anyway because i'm never
going to be here again
right you got that this is your halftime
speech okay
it's halftime and you're behind
we got to get you to win the game
you can do this i gotta get there but
you can't keep doing what you've been
doing so george is right are you gonna
cut up the credit cards all of them no
exceptions as soon as you get off the
phone say yes and mean it
yes okay i am good
along with that we're gonna send you
every dollar and the premium version
it'll connect to your bank this is going
to be your budgeting app this is going
to be your roadmap this is going to tell
you where you can and can't spend it's
it's your permission to play and so once
you set that up along with watching the
financial piece videos it's going to
give you a sense of control you've
probably never had because you're paying
attention to every single dollar that's
coming in from that amazing 83 000
income and we're gonna put it to good
use and every expense that is not
necessary for survival is going to go
away for a short period of time no
lifestyle no eating out
no vacations we're cleaning this mess up
because we're sick of living on the edge
of terror or the rest of our life
right
you can eat out later stop eating out
yeah we stopped eating out yeah well
something's wrong with your budget which
something's wrong with your budget
because you're not something's missing
in what you're telling us which makes me
think you're not really doing a good
detailed budget
i think this stuff is still happening to
you but i want to teach you to happen to
it
so every dollar has an assignment before
the month begins you make 83 000 a year
is our stop your retirement temporarily
do you have retirement coming out
i do stop it temporarily today
i want that money to go towards this
debt i want you to get where you ten
dollars is not okay left over
it's not that's the definition of terror
when you're by yourself
and you have to look in the eyes of your
baby
and you're scared
and you know you're just you're you're
walking around this 300 pound weight
around your neck i want to get it off of
you and so and i don't know what else is
coming out of your check but if you can
stop it stop it anything you can stop
that not not your health insurance keep
it but oh my goodness and any scorched
earth
food shelter clothing transportation
utilities and other than that kiddo
you're getting out of debt because if
you didn't have a stinking payment in
the world and you had a budget where you
were making your money behave instead of
wondering where it went your life would
be completely different than it is right
now and we haven't even moved you
towards building wealth yet
right you're going there though
okay
now you promise me you'll do this stuff
if i give it to you free
i promise all right here's what i want
you to do i want you to call back and
tell us how you're doing i want you to
call back if you get any questions if
you're scared you feel like you're by
yourself you're not we're here for you
thank you
you can do this but i gotta tell you now
if you don't do it i'm gonna kick your
butt okay
okay deal
we go to dallas enough dave might find
you out there
we'll be there for smart conference you
know what i want to send katie a ticket
to smart conference as well
can you do that officer yeah yeah we're
gonna be there october 22nd maybe we can
get to meet her i would love that that
will arrange that yeah and that'll give
her some encouragement all day long in
every area that event will overlap a lot
of fire under me i mean that event is
just i take from every speaker on that i
i love that thing it's some of the best
speakers and teachers in the world and i
i sit in the audience and take notes
every time we have one of those yeah
yeah yeah the thing is folks you can do
this stuff it's hard though
but you got to be different than the
world be not conformed to this world
you got to be weird that's why we always
yell at these people these young couple
paid off their house a while ago you're
dead free you're weird you guys are
weirdos people think i'm calling them
names i'm not calling names that's a
huge compliment when it comes from us
because normal sucks
normal is broke and scared
making a lot of money and having no idea
where it went normal as you work your
whole life and you retire and social
insecurity is supposed to take care of
you the government which is well known
for its ability to handle money is your
source come on
come on it's ridiculous and this toxic
money culture is a terrible measuring
stick to look at your broke friends and
go well i think i'm doing okay because
i'm doing as good as my friends are
there's toxic culture period you can't
look at the normal person's marriage and
go i want to be like that
no
because most of them don't have good
marriage they're not doing the right
stuff most of them don't have good
mental health most of them don't have
good careers you know you don't want to
be normal
god did not put you on this earth
there's a reason we look up to people
that are winning in an area of their
life is because they're winning
you know it's because they're doing good
stuff they're making a decision to
sacrifice no discipline seems pleasant
at the time but it yields a harvest of
righteousness you can do this stuff
folks and katie can do it and uh we're
going to love her so much that we're
going to encourage her and we're going
to kick her butt both whatever we got to
do to get her to go get it done
and that's because we love her whatever
it takes that's how it works man that's
how it works this is the ramsay show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships
george campbell ramsey personality host
to the fine print and the entree
leadership podcast on ramsey networks is
my co-host today open phones here at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five zak starts off this hour in
evansville indiana hi zach how are you
hey georgian dave hey what's up i'm a
catholic in a
i'm trying to make sure again
that's all right so i'm a catholic i've
recently had a few conversations with
other catholics on the topic of work
some of them have an almost socialist
perspective on it they think workers
today in the western world are facing
poor working conditions they argue for a
four-day work week and they say their
employers don't care about them
in some ways i can understand their
concern as christians don't want others
to be taken advantage of however i
disagree with their position
dave i was wondering what you would say
to these people as someone who is
christian encourages hard work
long work when needed and as someone who
owns a business
well um
there's two sides to the equation
there's the employer side and the
employee side
um i'm an employer
um and as a
person of faith that means i have a
responsibility
to serve
and treat my team well
okay
as a dad
i have a responsibility to
nurture serve and take care of my
children
when they're minors in my home
taking care of them also includes
requiring that they brush their teeth
that they say yes sir and no sir
that they say thank you
and learn gratitude
that they learn to work
loving them well my children when they
were little
included teaching them to work included
teaching them things
that if you were to ask them
when i was requiring them to clean up
their room when they were four
they could say
well my dad has unfair working
conditions
he's requiring too much of me at four
years old
but the truth is i could have cleaned up
their room easier than it was to talk
them into doing it
but then
they would have learned nothing and they
would have gained no dignity
as an employer it's different than
parenting
but uh there are some parallels in that
my goal or my job as a person of faith
is to serve my team but serving my team
also sometimes includes allowing them to
work somewhere else because they suck at
their job
we set them free in jesus name
i had a young man here that was in sales
many years ago and he um
he was really bad
at sales
and we kept talking to him about it and
finally one of our leaders serving him
sat down with him and said you know
young man you suck at this what is it
that you want to do with your life he
said i really want to be a photographer
and we said okay well let me help you
show you how to be a photographer we
actually have a small business thing
here called entre leadership and we
coached him and loved him and fired him
because he was awful
at sales
oh by the way he's now a world-class
photographer
some of the album covers that you see
i'm from nashville artists the guy shot
but he sucked as a salesman
so that is you know what are unfair
working conditions that mean old ramsey
people fired me well you sucked and
guess what you went on to become the
best possible version of yourself and we
were loving you well when we fired you
we actually cared about you
when we were firing you
we actually cared about you
when your mama had cancer and we paid
for
your airline ticket to go visit her we
actually cared about you when we do all
these things to serve you and help you
and love you but we also actually
require that while you're here at work
that you work
and i don't really want to hear about
your whining in your social activism
i'll fire your little butt for that
so you know we're not going to unionize
it ramsay i can just promise you that
it's not going to happen i'll just shut
the dead gun place down
so you know here's the thing you work
you get paid you do the work you get
loved we love each other we're all
working together to pull off the same
thing i don't know why a bunch of adults
can't do this i don't know why we have
to juxtaposition
employers against employees
in order to call that some kind of
spiritual movement the goal the truth is
we're supposed to love each other
i'm supposed to love them well and
they're supposed to love us back and do
their work
and um
it's not me extracting
from the labor market uh and not them uh
extracting from me in the name of some
twisted form of fairness that they came
up with and somehow put jesus on that
that one's really ridiculous
but you know some people can put jesus
on anything and put jesus on a peanut
butter sandwich and call it theology
it's ridiculous but it's not theology
it's a peanut butter sandwich
so
um that's a brand new sentence for me
right oh gosh but yeah i mean so yeah no
i'm with you zack i mean you read your
little statement i disagree with your
friends it's not anything to do with
catholicism versus protestant promise i
can't even say it
protestantism it's got it's got to do
with a clean view of scripture which
involves loving each other well
do unto others as you have them do unto
you treat your neighbor love your
neighbor as you love yourself the second
of the greatest commandments
jesus said to catholics and the
protestants
equally
and so you know this idea that all
employers are evil and should be
punished and all form here because for
some of these little snowflakes work at
all is unfair it's not fair that we have
to work to live dave it's unfair that
you require me to work while i'm at work
and i want to work from home where i
don't really work
but i'm at home
and i still collect a check
and oh by the way i've got three of
those work-at-home jobs now which means
i'm now stealing officially
from that employer
which is a new trend in work at home by
the way
go ahead and get three full-time jobs
while you work at home get paid by all
three of them for working full-time and
you're obviously aren't while you're
sitting on your mortgage that's called
stealing okay that's a lack of integrity
to say the least you're a thief so all
of that to say zach this idea that
socialism or capitalism
is either one the answer it's not it's
sanctified
capitalism meaning that people are
loving
the other person well in the equation
i actually do love our team
and i actually have done unbelievable
sacrifices for them
and we proved that during our downtime
during covet as an example
where we said the first people that
aren't going to get paid if somebody
doesn't get paid is leadership it didn't
it didn't result in that we were able to
keep profits up and everybody was able
to get paid yeah but that was how we
lined it out we said the leaders go
first
uh leaders go first leaders eat last
according to simon sinek but leaders go
first on not on taking the pain
and so you love your team well and in
return if you are an employer you should
work your butt off you should do your
work as unto the lord 3 23 in the bible
okay here we go so i mean do your work
is under the lord does that sound like
do your work is under i want to work
four days a week and i went after work
and i want to [ __ ] and complain about
my employer does that sound like doing
your work as under the lord to me
doesn't sound like it to me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones a triple eight
eight two five five
two two five so george and i are talking
at the break about that last uh caller
and he's telling me stuff that i didn't
know because i'm an old dinosaur
apparently that you said there is a uh
whole work uh anti-workers rise of the
anti-work movement
the group of people that think it is
unfair that they should have to work
and they're frustrated with the nature
of their employment
so therefore because i hate my employer
i should just not have to work the
nature of employment
okay
all right and if and if the young man
was asking me the christian
response to that um
you know uh
so here's what's interesting the
christian response is always
loving
but sometimes is so bold and in your
face
when you read scripture
that it's offensive
so like
paul said in the bible though he was
instructing
those that won't work don't let them eat
so that would be a christian response to
the what's it called the anti-work
movement yes there's a movement of
people that don't think they should have
to work that they should just be given
stuff by society yeah
just because it's unfair and all working
conditions therefore are unfair
correct yeah
and there's i mean i just pulled up
there's about a litany of of scripture
that is very clear even without the
biblical context you know ephesians let
the thief no longer steal rather let him
labor doing honest work with his own
hands so that he may have something to
share with anyone in need
look at that our proverbs he whoever is
slack in his work is a brother to him
who destroys
and i love there's one that i always
think of when i'm grilling
um
and it's uh
i can't remember the scripture because i
can't quote it exactly but it basically
says
a a an unfaithful servant is like smoke
to the eyes oh
you know you get the smoke in your eyes
and your eyes are watering yeah and so
when you have an employee
that is an idiot
it's like the grilling and the smoke is
in your face you know i mean it's like
that's what you're dealing with and so
if you got an employer that's an idiot
it'd be a similar thing i'm sure but oh
my gosh this is a song compared to the
you know talking about the anti-work
movement proverbs 14 23 and all toil
there's profit but mere talk tends only
to poverty
sounds like there's a lot of talk out
there dave
well the the thing is
um
you kind of just have to back up and go
okay if i was
your dad and you were doing that and you
were under my control i mean if you were
a teenager in other words you weren't an
adult living on your own then you get to
do what you want when you do that i
guess but but if i if i was someone who
loved you
and could influence you because i loved
you and i wanted what is good for you
then i've got to look at you and go
kind of have a dr phil moment here i
mean like how's it working for you
how's that working
this is not working thing how's the not
working thing working for you
you know
and um you know because you kind of do
that like with communism or socialism
you can go around the world in history
and look and go where there has been
communism where there's been socialism
you just look at them and go
so
you know how's that working for you
like when you're driving through israel
okay
uh you you go into the areas that are
controlled by the jewish community
they're
prosperous safe
clean you're going to the areas
controlled by the plo
looks like a trailer park
it's awful
and you just kind of want to look at
them and go guys how's it working for
you
you know how's that working for you
what's the fruit of
your ideas
when you put your best idea forward and
you get poop back
how's that working for you
you know how's the thing not work thing
working for you yeah man because you
love somebody i don't want you to you
know how's the being in debt thing
working for you it's not that's why you
called us we're gonna get you out of
debt you know so yeah
and to your point you talked about
parents and how you know you make your
kids clean their room and it's forced
labor or whatever it is the thing about
working into the salt mines you can't
choose your parents but you can choose
your employer
so imagine that you can just
choose to find a place that doesn't suck
i don't think they pay enough okay don't
go to work there
if you think you're worth i think
they're a toxic work environment that
guy's a narcissist everybody's a
narcissist now everybody that you don't
like is now a narcissist
that's a redefinition of that term
anybody i don't like narcissist that's
how you define it
so uh yeah i and so don't work there
don't have a choice don't work there
you don't no one forced you to work
there half the show is just telling
america that you have agency over your
life you have control
but the problem is people back
themselves into a corner and decide they
only have one option it's to work for a
toxic place or not work at all
and that's just not the case no it's not
true there's a lot of wonderful
organizations that exist in capitalism
and treat their people well including
their customers
and do a great job
are they perfect no they're not perfect
institutions they're run by human beings
and they're but they're all over the
place and i know a bunch of them
and if you think you could do better go
start you a business and run it the
right way we need more of that in
america go for it yeah take that take
that um
not working thing and go hire a bunch of
people with it
and see how that works out and pay them
with the not money that you don't make
here we go
great business model
love it uh so yeah in those hungry
people that need to be fed
um
you're not gonna be feeding them because
you ain't gay money
your generosity level because you're a
broke person
by the way all communists are broke
people
they generally happen because there's
nothing more capitalistic than a
non-broke communist
um they all need to we all need to read
uh rabbi lapin's book yeah
prospero so what's great gems in there
and it'll give you it'll give you a real
spiritual look on work
the jewish community he talks he's
orthodox rabbi he talks about the jewish
community the work the hebrew word for
work and the word for worship is very
similar he said on sunday we have
worship service and on monday we have
customer service
and they're both worship
they're both workship so when you are
working and doing your work as under the
lord
it is honoring it's an honoring thing
spiritually you're honoring god with
that
so uh you're to sit on your butt and
scream about everyone else and gripe
about everyone else uh there is nothing
christian about that at all i think
that's called gossip
so anyway it's very interesting
discussion it's a fun life mission i
guess to be angry at work and just
strike no it's not fun because they're
angry all the time being angry all the
time is not fun well that's why reddit
exists dave that's where they all go
twitter twitter and reddit twitter and
reddit um well at least you have a place
to vent and and someone can pretend to
care but and it's free so that's nice
they don't have to pay for it but you
know the whole thing of i'm gonna that's
why i you know i've had i've turned off
twitter i don't i don't look at it
anymore
because there's nothing on there but
anger and i don't i quit watching the
news i don't i don't turn on the news
anymore i just um if you're not on
twitter you don't have to block people
so that that's i don't know that's the
downside had some fun with that that's
the downside i had the record for most
blocks a guy reached out and dm me and
said hey why did dave block me as if i'm
i have the reason you're one of 40 000
dude i mean something you said was
pretty offensive you're not special
you're not that special
but yeah please unblock me i'm i don't
know i'm not even on there anymore just
forget it go on to something that's
relevant to your life and twitter is not
on the list
so yeah it's this is an interesting
discussion though yeah we're babbling a
little bit because there's a lot of
emotion around i just did not know there
was a real thing i mean that's from the
bbc they did a huge piece on it a real
thing called the anti-work movement
that's like the
man you could have an anti-anything
movement that's right that's pretty cool
but i think everyone needs to read ken's
book from paycheck to purpose if they're
you know in this world because what
we're saying is work is not evil
work is actually good for us and we just
need to find the right kind of work at
the right place let me just tell you
that
there is nothing
the human psyche is built to have
traction
there is no
psychological benefit to doing something
that has no traction
work involves traction that's why i like
pressure washing you get to see the
stuff clean up while you're doing it
that's why people like to mow grass you
get to see when you're done you gotta do
it again next week but you get to see
when you're done right it's it's you
know when you're doing something you
need to feel the sense of accomplishment
and traction
incremental progress along the way it's
a psychological need that the human
brain has
and to actually do nothing
is psychologically
suicide
because your your brain is going to rot
inside your head
so that that's it really doesn't work on
so many levels
psychologically economically spiritually
and that's why your loving heavenly
father gives you instructions to work
there we go good word there's your
sunday sermon movement is not biblical
there we go ding ding that's a headline
dave be careful this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host in the lobby of ramsey solutions
james and ashlara are with us hey guys
how are you hey mr ramsay welcome where
do you guys live charleston south
carolina oh it's a great town welcome to
nashville yes sure and how much debt
have you guys paid off 397
218 dollars and 20 cents boom wow how
long did this take 36 months 36 months
you were rocking that what was your
range of income during that time 80 000
to 250. oh there's a little jump in
three years
just a tiny bit so what in the world
happened with your jobs to start with
go ahead well i was gonna say so in the
middle of it you get started and then i
got laid off
and so we only had his income for about
three months um and then i got another
job and then i got a better job and you
know somewhere in the middle god shows
up after you've been faithful and i got
three bonuses in one year and so we just
took them all and went towards that ding
ding ding what do you do i'm an
accountant okay and what do you do i'm a
firefighter paramedic okay cool so yours
stayed stable and she went to nothing
and then went straight up yes sir okay
wow that's incredible all right so
you didn't make enough even with all of
that hardly to pay that much off you
must have sold something yes sir we sold
several things anything and everything
we could like you said we sold what did
you sell what was the biggest thing you
sold a motorcycle it's a car that we got
rid of okay how much did they go for
the motorcycle was right at thirty two
thousand wow
yeah it just it was it was it was
correct bike was that
a dumb decision is what's kind of like
no it sounds like an awesome bike what
was it uh uh no it wasn't indian yeah in
india it was it was so fun it was a
great bike but thirty two thousand
dollars for the motorcycle yes sir
that's a sweet bike though i bet you
cried a little uh i did a little bit but
looking back it was absolutely a dumb
decision and the best decision yeah it
was a very mature thing but they're
still the little boy inside goes
okay so
so the indian's gone and what was the
car it was a chevy cruze that we got rid
of yeah what did that sell for
right at 22 000. okay so 54 000
of this was those two things right okay
wow very cool all right what you guys
obviously
just did a complete about face i mean
you're like you changed everything yes
this is very radical i can see it in the
numbers yes sir so tell me what caused
this radical transformation and how you
got connected to us
well i guess we just like you've said we
got tired of being sick and tired of
being sick and tired and then we were
just stupid on steroids as dave says
and you just wake up and you're tired of
living like that you're tired of living
the norm you're tired of being like
everyone else and you just make that
decision that this is going to change
we did get married in 19 2019 and we
knew going in that we were bringing debt
and we were completely honest with each
other but we also
in talking to each other we're like
we're not living like this anymore
um i'm sure we had heard through i do
believe a church is where we had
originally heard you from
kind of played around with it when we
first met but then when we got married
we made the commitment that we were
going to do this
um how did you get to our materials at
that point what would you do did you go
through fpu or read the book or we read
you
read the book and then we just watched
thousands and thousands of hours
seriously of of youtube videos and
everything we could and that's kind of
what brought us here today it was
hearing everyone else's dead scream that
we wanted to do that yeah yeah and we
got to this point
even during those difficult months when
i and i say difficult when all you're
doing is
eating peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches that sounds crazy yeah but we
wouldn't go to the grocery store because
we had peanut butter and jelly and bread
and it that's how serious we were about
doing it
and then we would just sit and watch
videos together of of you guys on tv
people other people talking other people
sharing their experiences um and that's
what got us through yeah there's several
thousand debt free screams on youtube oh
yeah on our youtube channel several
foundations we've now had we've now had
a billion downloads on youtube yeah it's
crazy yeah well you were our cheerleader
like we didn't have a cheerleader so you
were the encouragement we would listen
to debt free screenings all those people
like you yes sir encouragement because
you see yourself in every one of those
calls a little bit 100 but your thing
was you really had a beautiful thing
because you get married so you got a
fresh start on life yes and you're like
okay while we're at it we're going to
clean out the garage so while we're at
it the indian and the cruise is gone
right right exactly
and behavior that we had prior going
into just living like everyone else was
going to end
um and i say
in the middle of that we had just gotten
married and there were those difficult
times where all we were talking about
was this and
i i it was just that's when we had to go
back to the youtube videos because it
got very discouraging that we almost
lost each other during this we were so
determined doing the finance part of it
but now coming out on the we got to have
a honeymoon yeah we forgot to do us yeah
and we forgot it but because we were so
focused and so intent on doing this
and wanted to change because we had
between us we have eight kids we have
four apiece so we not only this we now
have eight kids that they're excited
that we're here they're following these
steps we have we have 21 year olds that
are both bought houses both have a 400k
both yeah so it's not we showed them how
to win yeah and we just yeah the ripple
effect of what you guys have done i mean
it will be felt for generations and that
was the biggest thing we were wanted to
make a generational change
starting right now wow yeah so did i
miss it what kind of debt was the 397
oh i didn't ask the side's stupid
besides the car in the motorcycle go
ahead so we had medical debt we had irs
debt we had you know state taxes debt we
had attorney fees from before we got
married credit card debt student yeah we
had 13 credit cards i was still paying
on my student loans from 10 years ago
how did you even keep up with the fees
you lost 300 pounds that's the thing is
it's a full-time job pay something and
somebody would come out of the woodwork
and say you oh by the way you owe us two
so you just tack it on to the end
yeah it was it's great to see that
number but then when you get there
you're like oh my god but how was i
living yeah you're excited about the
number being gone but then you're like
oh my god i did that it's great that
it's gone it's it's a tremendous
you talk about this all the time mr
ramsey it's a tremendous feeling that
it's off your shoulders right now yeah
you breathe differently at night you
absolutely do yeah and in reverse of
that or the other side of that we almost
lost each other but now we're we've
grown so much closer together doing this
um now it's it's totally changed our
very young marriage just in the past
couple years it's really changed our
marriage going forward you guys are
amazing you created margin in your money
but also in your time and in your life
and in your marriage so you can actually
focus instead of being stressed and
distracted amen that's incorrect you
guys are heroes i mean you got you
gained back many hours a month just not
having to pay these bills yeah there's a
lot of them oh my god everybody on the
list oh my gosh the irs the attorneys
the credit cards it was all there get in
line it was and it was you know many
nights of working double shifts
her work in doing taxes for other people
it was yeah we we spent a lot of time
away from each other
working because we were absolutely going
to do this and then was it worth it
absolutely yes sir yeah because you
still have life in the middle of that we
still lost her mom we still had another
death in the family you still have kids
graduation kids going into marines kids
just everything so yeah yeah it's we we
were determined mr ramsay we were going
to push this and get here you guys are
warriors 400 grand paid off yes sir an
incredible accomplishment it is in three
years it's just beautiful yeah yeah
we've we've gone from baby step one
everybody listening baby step one to
right now standing there we are making
double payments on the house now so
anybody everybody should hopefully we'll
know that yeah we are at that point
right now in 40 months we're ready to
work four five six now yeah yeah yeah
are working we are doing it yes sir way
to go very well done we got a copy of
baby steps millionaires for you that is
the next chapter in your story for sure
how ordinary people build extraordinary
wealth and how you can too that's where
you're going i'm proud of y'all thank
you thank you neat people thank you fun
to talk to you yes and we got a copy or
we got financial peace university which
you should have gone through
anyway but now we're gonna give it to
you free and you can go through it so
there you go you motivated a long enough
time you got the new joy yeah well it's
it'll take you on to the baby steps take
you on the babysitter's millionaire
status and george and uh dr john deloney
and george campbell and rachel cruz are
in the new videos along with me and also
a total money makeover book uh for you
to get going and may i already give away
to somebody who's trying to get going
you guys are very very impressive
james and ashlara from charleston south
carolina 397
000
paid off in 36 months 80 to 250 income
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three two one we're debt free
[Applause]
oh the newlyweds wow that's incredible
that's one way to start off your
marriage let's pay off 400 grand first
thing out of the gate first 40 months
yeah this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our scripture today galatians 6 9 and
let us not grow weary of doing good for
in due season we will reap
if we do not give up pablo picasso said
only put off until tomorrow what you're
willing to die having left undone
pretty strong on a little bit of
[ __ ] dark from pablo there you go
stepping up with a positive thinking
moment yeah oh my gosh hey right now if
you're hearing a lot of the talking
heads in the news stirring up fear about
the real estate market be careful don't
believe them it's not going to crash
um
it's going to slow down the economy has
slow has slowed down but
don't make decisions based on fear bank
them based on facts
and prices aren't going down values
aren't going down some of the prices are
going down because they were
unrealistically high but the values are
not dropping
so we're just going to grow and we're
going to grow at a slower rate it's
going to take a little harder a little
longer to sell a house than 48 hours
and uh probably more like 70 or 120 days
right you need an experienced real
estate agent when you're selling houses
in a market like this you need an
experienced real estate agent when
you're buying houses in a market like
this if you want to find who we trust
that's a high octane high protein
real estate agent ramsay trusted go to
ramseysolutions.com
agent check out our endorsed local
providers lee's in phoenix hi lee
welcome to the ramsey show
thank you very much what's up how can we
help
well i've received an insurance
settlement check of 174 000
and i know i'm going to make a donation
to my church but after that i need some
advice on how to spend the rest of it or
save it or whatever i need to do
okay cool
so um
well we would have we teach the shortest
distance between where you are and
wealthy is a process that we call the
baby steps yes so do you have any debt
currently
um i have a 15
000
loan on my car
but i don't have any credit card debt
and i do owe 136 on my mortgage okay and
what's your income
uh 60 000 a year
okay what was the settlement from
it was an
accident are you okay
back in 2020
thank the good lord yes
there's no ongoing medical issues or
health bills you're dealing with
well um i'm still waiting on a pending
25 000
that they're holding but i don't think
i'm going to owe anything else um
on this accident i think they've taken
care of everything so far okay and um i
do have you know i'm not doing therapy
now but i i am fine
but i am 84 years old so i'm not a young
chicken
how much you don't sound like it yeah
that surprised me when you said that wow
well most people don't think i'm that
old
do you have do you have money in
other money and savings
i have
about 55 000 in a 401k and some money
market prior to the accident and since
the accident before you received this
check how are you living
i was living an excellent life traveling
and doing all kinds of things
what are you using for income
i have pensions detentions and the
social security and that's what i live
on i don't know how much is that all of
that total up to a month
uh five thousand dollars excellent okay
all right um
if you were my mom here's what i would
tell you to do i'm 62. so that's a
that's a mathematical possibility okay
um so here's what i would tell you to do
i would tell you to pay off your house
in your car
okay now if you did that if you did that
the five thousand dollars goes a lot
further every month doesn't it
oh sure okay absolutely now if you have
zero debt in the whole world i want you
to breathe that in and feel that
how's that feel
wonderful thank you okay
and that's kind of why i'm having you do
it
i mean there's not a big financial thing
at 84 if you said i'm going to take all
this money and blow it and pay my
mortgage out of my
uh deal it doesn't ruin your life you're
living your life well already okay
and we're not really doing this for the
next 25 years
because that's probably statistically
not likely
right right well my grandmother lived to
be 105 so i'm i might have 20. you might
have 20 but not 25 that's why i said 25.
i know i don't know but the uh
[Laughter]
but the you're gonna challenge me dave
you're gonna push it all the way out to
the edge on my mouth here but the point
being that
what gives you the best quality of life
is what ran through my head
if i'm in your shoes for the next decade
and you've enjoyed really living life
well on five thousand dollars worth of
pensions to social security a month if
we take your payments out of that and
the weight that those payments have on
your shoulders on your back and on your
neck
if you if you don't have there's there's
literally a physical transaction that
occurs when you're no longer in debt
right you really do feel like you're
breathing cool mountain air
yes well that's what my thought was
because i know
that i don't need the money that's in my
401k
and if i have
money every month that i'm not putting
out in other things i can save that or i
can travel or i can do different things
that i would enjoy you've got
i want to do that as long as i can do
that i love it i i hope i'm like 130 136
and 15 is 151 out of 174
correct and you're debt-free and you can
still make that donation to the church
how cool is that and you can still book
a couple more trips yeah
yeah yeah well as i said too there's
another 25 000 pending which i the
attorneys assured me that i probably
will get and there's also possibilities
of some other that they're working on
but i i'm not banking on any of that i'm
banking on just what i have so
was it a car accident sounds like a plan
actually uh i was a pedestrian walking
when i was hit oh wow
by the grace of god i'm still here well
you're resilient that's impressive
yeah well
i figured the lord wasn't done with me
yet apparently
apparently
yeah he gets to decide that after all
huh so how long ago was the accident
um october of 2020 oh my goodness in the
middle of all that garbage
i mean how did you get hit by a car
nobody was driving so
no cars out there holly wow wow you're
amazingly well that's what i would do uh
the sense of peace
the sense of well-being
the weight that has been set down
is what i would want for you it's what
i'd want from me if i were in your shoes
well and when anyone retires i mean
going into retirement with no payments
in the world it changes how you make
decisions in retirement changes what you
can do it changes if you can take the
grandkids to disney that year
now she's figured out a way to do all
that on the 5000 really yeah but the
thing is
there's something almost in the air it's
just intangible it is spiritual it is
psychological um at this stage it's not
financial it's not even mathematical at
this stage
uh because the number of years we're
dealing with
um in in the equation you know the math
starts not being relevant in this
situation
but there is something precious
about the feeling that when you get up
in the morning and you're sitting on
your porch
and you're 84 and it's yours
that just is golden man
i
and i want to quantify i i you know i
want that i had that when i was in my
you know my 30s
because i quit borrowing money paid off
everything right
but a lot of people don't you had that
you know in your 30s yeah but i you know
you know with all she's been through too
yeah she needs to enjoy
that
and she's an upbeat optimistic
incredible lady you know
but having gone through that horrible
accident obviously and she doesn't need
the money to put food on the table so
that's kind of what we're trying to get
out is how much does she need this
settlement money to live and she doesn't
if she had a
no pension and was trying to live on
social security i might change that
but she's got everything set up this is
like extra money in a sense it's not
like she's overdone actually got a ton
of money but it's just um
so really what we're getting here is a
quality of life issue
kind of thing
oh so i don't know if you can quantify
it but will she live longer without a
mortgage payment i don't know
i
think there's a case to be made for that
i doubt you could probably back it up
with empirical research that's ever been
done because i've never seen that but um
yeah you know stress
is uh the big one hypertension kills
people you know
so she doesn't sound too stressed to me
though
that puts the sour the ramsay show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
do you love a good dave rand want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you